well thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much please said thank
you this
is without question the latest news
conference i've ever had
thank you thank you
i appreciate it very much and i want to
thank the american people for their
tremendous support
millions and millions of people voted
for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
and we won't stand for it we will not
stand here
i want to thank the first lady my entire
family
and vice president pence mrs pence
for being with us all through this
and we were getting ready for a big
celebration
we we were winning everything and all of
a sudden it was just
called off the results tonight have been
phenomenal and we are getting ready i
mean literally we were just
all set to get outside and
just celebrate something that was so
beautiful so good
such a vote such a success the citizens
of this country have come out
in record numbers this is a record
there's never been anything like it
to support our incredible movement we
won states that we weren't expected to
win florida we didn't win it
we won it by a lot and
we won the great state of ohio
we won texas we won texas
we won texas by 700 000 votes and they
don't even
include it in the tabulations
it's also clear that we have won georgia
we're up by 2.5
or 117 000 votes with
only seven percent left they're never
going to catch us they can't catch us
likewise we've clearly won north
carolina
where we're up 1.4
or 77 000 votes with only
approximately five percent left i can't
catch us
we also if you look and you see
arizona we have a lot of life in that
and somebody said somebody declared
that it was a victory for us and maybe
it will be i mean that's possible
but certainly there were a lot of votes
out there that we could get
because we're now just coming into what
they call trump territory i don't know
what you call it but these were friendly
trump voters
and that could be overturned the
gentleman that called it i watched
tonight
he said well we think it's fairly
unlikely that he could catch well fairly
unlikely
and we don't even need it we don't need
that that was just
a state that if we would have gotten it
would have been nice arizona but
there's a possibility maybe even a good
possibility in fact
since i saw that originally it's been
changed and the numbers have
substantially come down
just in a small amount of votes so
we want that obviously to stay in play
but most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
we're up 600 think of this think of this
think of this
we're up 690 000 votes in pennsylvania
690 000
these aren't even close it's not like oh
it's close
with 64 of the
vote end it's going to be almost
impossible to catch and we're coming
into
good pennsylvania areas where they
happen to like your president
so we'll probably expand that uh
we're winning michigan but i'll tell you
i looked at the numbers i said
whoa i looked i said wow
that's a lot by almost 300
000 votes and
65 of the vote is in
and we're winning wisconsin and i said
well we don't need all of them
we need because when you add texas in
which wasn't added
i spoke with the really wonderful
governor of texas just a little while
ago and greg abbott he said
congratulations he called me to
congratulate me on winning texas i mean
we won texas i don't think they finished
quite the tabulation but there's no way
and it was almost complete but he
congratulated me
then he said by the way what's going on
i've never seen anything like this
can i tell you what nobody has so we won
by 107 000 votes with 81 percent of the
vote that's michigan
so when you take those three states in
particular
and you take all of the others i mean we
have we have so many we had such a big
night you just take a look at all of
these states that we've won tonight
and then you take a look at the kind of
margins that we've want to buy
and and all of a sudden it's not like
we're up 12 votes and we have
60 percent left we won states and all of
a sudden
i said what happened to the election
it's off
and we have all these announcers saying
what happened and then they said oh
because you know what happened
they knew they couldn't win so they said
let's go to court and did i predict this
newt did i say this
i've been saying this from the day i
heard they were going to send out tens
of millions of ballots they said exactly
because either they were going to win or
if they didn't win
they'll take us to court so florida was
a tremendous victory
377 000. texas as we say
ohio think of this
ohio a tremendous state a big state i
love ohio we won by
one 8.1 four hundred and sixty-one think
of it
almost 500 000 votes north carolina big
victory with north carolina
and so we won there we lead by
76 000 votes with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and we will win this and we as far as
i'm concerned
we already have for it so i just want to
thank you
and i want to thank all of our
support i want to thank all of the
people that
worked with us and mr vice president
say a few words please